optimiste
ce n est vraiment dit
je suis à l'aise de temps je suis
directeur du centre international de
marins ou vie c'est super et de
bien-être des gens ne mène aumôniers et
puis je suis marié et père de deux
enfants le bonjour bonjour ça devenait
aller c'est bien je n'ai cédé merci pour
cette journée que l'on voit apparaître
son soleil
et c'est pour ça
ce climat c'est poli de la région merci
début de ma famille et de mes amis
devenus ceux qui me sont chers de bénir
nos élus et bien au seigneur cette
journée qu'elle soit agréable que de
protection dans ma vie c'est un beau
t-shirt pourrais je portais cela parce
que bientôt ce la coupe du monde et non
le qualifier pour assister la coupe du
monde à battre le matin visite de jardin
voici tout bon et puis et préparer peu
de cacahuètes comme j'ai pas le temps ce
moment de préempter gêné et ça donne
bien c'est bio et sans engrais et sans
produits chimiques
et bien que les composent je n'ai pas
les passions il fait pas de sport ne
fait pas grand chose sauf le travail en
deux temps c'est au jardin
non ça sera pour le bien-être en ces
moments de méditation moment de repos
moment de convivialité la terre et ça
c'est ça qui me repose
quand j'étais mon gazon j'ai pour moi
c'est c'est pas les essais physiques
c'est plus le repos comme le sucre en
caisse ma façon de l'être voilà on vient
la maison
et
alors ouais je voyageais avec j'ai mis
dans l'avion jusqu'à j'ai repensé à ma
d'oubli de l'avion j'ai fait le voyage
avec jusqu'à la réunion la peine oubliée
de chaque avion passe comme j'ai tapé 49
heures de vol dont parce que j'étais à
san diego sur le site 815 beijer de
mission en mission humanitaire
sans compter les pays que je suis parti
plusieurs plusieurs fois et et d'europe
ne compte pas dansé par rapport à ce que
j'ai vu qu'on vise à voilà et ça c'est
là tu vas voir très intéressant quand
j'allais souvent l'église c'est le
vuvuzela jamais vraiment ce qui me
marque comme vuvuzelas ce symbole de la
fille que ces symboles de la delà de la
joie de la fête l'animation dont céder
la victoire vous vous lassez sent bon la
victoire maintenant hélas se voit les
bateaux au port donc actuellement il ya
un deux trois quatre cinq bateaux deux
cargos et sain et trois porte conteneurs
là je me dis que aujourd'hui le travail
sera intense on aura énormément démarré
au centre
la sas et due forme des deux mondes
travail et qui nous est donnée envoyée
par l'angleterre
donc c'est la society donc sa majesté
qu'il a un patron de notre organisation
protestants
entendu parce que moi je dois pas donner
l'image de quelqu'un qui fait pitié
il faut donner l'image des gens l'envié
de pouvoir avoir soif de se dire que tu
sais pas si nous n'avons pas un jeu
uniquement de pauvreté nous avons
indiens aussi de richesse c'est écrit la
bible de dit clairement dons parce qu'on
a tendance de croire que le passé doit
être le plus malheureux
non ce n'est pas ça ce n'est pas ce que
la bible nous enseigne
là vraiment des bateaux général rouge et
travailleur aujourd'hui tout est codé
avant on n'avait pas ça c'est vrai que
je suis aumônier protestant et traque de
tous les protestants et travers d'un
aumônier catholique mais quand nous
sommes à bord dans la vie on n'a pas
notre étiquette aumônier en aumônerie
tous les marins qui soit 1,10 qui soit
vous disent qu'ils soient je sais pas de
n'importe quelle religion de là pour
servir ce mag outre bon ça sent bon
quand ses aventures jusqu aux
commandeurs
vraiment très ouvert de commandes elles
reçoivent la télévision celle d'autres
demandes fermes et non en bâtiment qui
sert de travail et savent la valeur que
nous avons hélas maintenant le visage
change
le karaté change le comportement chambas
qui m'est arrivé plusieurs heures
n'adopte d'arriver dans un bateau le
mari m'a dit vous avez les bons de
quelque chose à cacher à vendre non sur
une plate forme selon vous sa vie et
avant je fais partie du jeu je suis le
foyer des marins il ya bon c'est loin
d'ici comment on peut faire je la
commence en frontal est en confiance
au moment où mathieu bastareaud
madagascar et bershka mataba nova hawk
est dans le marais au milieu de la mer
qu'est-ce qui voit le ciel et la mer
et là il voit la terre y voit les hommes
les hommes différents de ce qu'ils ont
envie de voir dans les bateaux ça casse
un peu la monotonie et c'est quelque
chose d'important
les marins vie font partie des
catégories sociales très faible très pas
parce que les marins d'une part déjà ils
ont payant de la scène travaille
vraiment humain ce travail social que
l'on romarin même chypre a chanté un
dessinateur qui on peut vérifier et voir
le nombre d'enfants accueillis durant
voilà et isabelle c'est un emploi de
dany très jeune pour servir quand j en
algérie deux légionnaires et puis jean
marie vient d'ajuster d'arrivée voilà
jean marie et puis il l'appelait
polyvalent
internet est à situer le tempo leurs
familles ce qui fait qu'il faille pour
la vodka
skype est pas du temps quand je parle de
mon travail à d'autres personnes nous
avons ça existe ça ne savent pas et
c'est exister c'est toujours une
découverte pour les autres jeunes
explique mon travail il faut enlever
jallet 7 ou non parce que la charge
énorme
c'est patrick mince affaire dans chaque
batterie en moyenne 20 marins mais tu
plais 20 passes et ça fait un énorme don
en moyens nous allons vous disant pas
année treize mouvements qui fait escale
au port la réunion et nous recevons 1600
marin au son des marins dont il faut
vraiment être rigoureux être organisée
c'est important organisé dans son
travail
on sait qui fait quoi et à quel moment
il faut le faire et être disciplinés
dans ce qu'on fait à dessein de
transport pour les marins les et de
retourner au point et de ce qu'on peut
les amener au centre commercial et des
os et qu'on peut les amener se promener
et se balader et pour visiter la réunion
non c'est une tradition dans son nom
arrive dans un port on a le centre on
cherche le foyer des marins
et puis lorsqu'on tourne le foyer c'est
un lieu où nous avons un grand service
ou auxquels on peut être en comptant une
famille
dans le sens des marins nous avons une
place de prière pour les marins du
recueillement où le marabout venez ya
aussi une place les marins pour se
confier à nous passer le marin et non
pas seulement les difficultés et on sait
difficultés d'autres si chic d'autres
sickology de difficultés entre les
personnages du bateau cabines
téléphoniques sur place pour certains
pays et home cinéma juste quand occupe
le marin ici ça c'est les chambres
pourquoi on ne sont figés les maîtres
privé parce qu'on est marin surtout les
asiatiques tous qui t'appartient
appartient nous obligés de d'empêcher
qui passe sinon il en est visité par
tous nous avons des vélos pour le
transport
là ce sont des chambres d'hébergement
depuis un temps on n'a pas beaucoup de
marge des passages ici c'est le conseil
général que la mairie du port on met à
la disposition poulaire pour quand le
115 est plein et cette chambre aussi et
cette pièce on peut l'utiliser comme
chambre lorsqu'il ya eu des marais
naufragés qui se passe et on était plein
on a les pico la madame l'armée nous a
prétendu que cause on est quatre lits
picots ici et j'étais confortablement là
une chambre qui occupaient toujours
aussi ya actuellement sept étudiants de
l'école d'apprendre ça ma rétine qui
vient de mayotte qui est logique dans ce
mon bureau que je suis rarement au
bureau terme en 69 alors ça fait six ans
que l'as mandé construit c'est pas si
vous sentez un peu de neuf voilà comme
ça c'est beau bureau que avec les
honneurs militaires pour que je n'oublie
pas notre centre a été élu en 2011 comme
le meilleur centre pour le bien-être des
gens de m
tu vois des partants des papas et la
maison implantée papa et j'ai planté ici
j'ai planté par les fat a noté mist
il fonce et là un projet en tête et il
va le réussir à tout prix
est ce que vous avez envie de dire à aux
réunionnais sur ces gens là qui se
balade dans le port et j'ai envie de
dire aux réunionnais de ça pour les
approcher de dire au moins bon jour de
leur demander ce qu'ils ont besoin de
quelque chose
voyez donc ce sont des gens qui passent
au moins de trois mois en mer ils ont
besoin de communiquer la communication
est importante
donc quand ils arrivent chez nous ils
communiquent avec la famille d'accord
mais quand il se balade tout seul en un
dimanche après midi
si pauvre malheureuse en personne
parfois les gens sont indifférents
devant ce visage inconnu
merci beaucoup les marins sont
indispensables aux réunionnais parce que
tout ce qui est bien à la réunion plus
de 95% de ce que nous consommons vient
par voie maritime et parfois on a fait
de la mer on n'a pas la fête des gens de
mer heureusement que depuis 2010 l'onu
l'opération en ans va maritime a mis en
place une journée pour rendre hommage
aux 1 million 500 mille marin qui
navigue à travers le monde vous dit et
moi je dis revenez quand vous mettez le
riz dans la mare it pensée d'où vient ce
riz à quai les marins
ce n'est pas un luxe c'est une nécessité
c'est même une obligation